[Musique]
et
vous voyez voir les problèmes de santé
rencontrés par les personnes en
situation de précarité en rue
et aussi tout ce qui est liée à
l'injection
infectieuses vih hépatites
[Musique]
au
moins de risque et si tu fais nausées
sont là
pas de stress au niveau de la police si
tu te gect le regard des gens même quand
ça fait des années qu'on pense à me
rentrer quand même désir
niveau de flouter de s'injecter
attention super mal il faudrait mieux
parce que le ski
[Musique]
ca c
actuellement on est à 150 160 passages
par jour
avant le coc vide on était plutôt à 300
350 passages par jour on s'est retrouvé
avec un afflux
on n'imaginait pas
voilà après c'est ça se gère mais ça
veut dire que s'est plaint tout le temps
de l'ouverture quasiment jusqu'à la
fermeture
[Musique]
à
ce
[Musique]
il a faim
il
[Musique]
un
quartier où mois de matin je descends je
promène mon gamin à l'école tout se
passe bien on est serein on est dans un
petit village
malheureusement c'est tout ce qui risque
de changer si jamais on a une population
en souffrance là pour dire on n'est pas
laboratoire expérimentations et si
effectivement la salle de shoot permet
comme j'ai entendu sur les plateaux télé
une intelligence collective une
solidarité que ces gens là qui
connaissent le bien pour les autres je
la paie calmels qui s'installe salles de
shoot chez eux ça s'est elle installée à
salade de chou à l'hôtel de ville
voilà mais ça réduit les overdoses ça
réduit les problèmes de santé liés à
l'injection et à la consommation de
drogue ça réduit le nombre de passages
aux urgences
l'étude a montré même que ça réduit la
criminalité que dans quartier le
commissaire du 10e ledit
systématiquement il ya plus de sujets
vraiment de sécurité par rapport à ce
qui se passait avant il ya moins de
seringue dans la rue donc même au niveau
de la tranquillité publique c'est un
impact
ça sort les personnes de la rue
[Musique]
ce